well thank you all for coming this
morning so professor Ramirez is the one
that conceived of science Saturdays and
ran it single-handedly for a couple
years before I came on and in classic
professor Ramirez fashion she agreed to
introduce herself this morning and tell
you how fabulous she was but of course
she wouldn't tell you that what she
would say is you know I'm here I do some
nice science and so forth and so on but
I want you all to know how amazing she
is so science Saturday's wise this
exists because of her you know no one
said hey this would be kind of cool she
said it and she made it happen
and so you all should really so besides
doing science Saturday's which is easily
I think one of the coolest things on the
planet although I am a little biased
she's also an extraordinary scientist so
professor Ramirez started her science
career at Brown University proudly
started it actually when she was two
years old I'm guessing doing something
cool along the way but started at Brown
University and went on to Stanford to
get her PhD and then worked at Bell Labs
and Bell Labs was probably the greatest
think tank there was for doing cool
materials work and Professor Emeritus
was probably one of their coolest people
there that really came up with some
novel materials when I went into science
people started saying things like
there's nothing that interesting and
materials we know everything we need to
know about materials at this point a
professor Ramirez has proved people
wrong there's a lot we can learn about
materials especially if we have people
like her that are incredibly creative
and phenomenally wonderful besides being
an absolutely amazing scientist she's in
fact one of the coolest people here at
Yale she's a phenomenal friend she's a
great mentor to a huge host of us here
she looks after all of us and she
actually she's just one of the great
people so let's give her a big hand for
doing this event
I had to pay Aaron a lot of money for
that so I feel like I got my money's
worth
all right well today I'm gonna talk to
you about strange stuff I'm gonna talk
to you a little bit about smart
materials and nanotechnology all right
so I'm a material scientist and I think
a lot about stuff not possessions but
just stuff and so what I'm gonna talk to
you a little bit about today is smart
stuff and then I'll talk to you a little
bit about very small stuff okay so we're
gonna talk about stuff today so I mean
is that okay all right
so let me just do a survey so that we're
all on the same page
how many of you won't use one of these
okay any of you use one of these a TV
yeah maybe too much of it sometimes
anybody use one of these oh by the way
shut them off how about one of these all
right
so for the most part everybody's part of
the 21st century that's great
well all of these things have in common
this which is circuitry
there's resistors transistors capacitors
and they're all put into place into this
green circuit board and they're held
into place at locations like that using
a material seen those cellphones are
going off using a material called solder
now although there's an L in there and
although I'm from New Jersey I'm saying
it right it's solder okay in the UK
they'll say solder but here we say
solder and solder is the material that
puts into place all of these different
components all right
so let's talk a little bit more about
solder solder is a low melting point
metal if I were to give you a piece of
solder I have a piece here and you put
it on a frying plan not your mom's
favorite firing pan but if you hit heat
this up on the stove it will melt it's a
metal that will melt at such low
temperatures it's also malleable that's
just a big big word for saying that it's
bendable can you say malleable malleable
means bendable it's used to join meaning
that it's like a glue it's a metallic
you can put two medals together and you
can still have electricity pass and it's
often made of two or more metals so when
you have two or more metals mixed
together
that's called an alloy can you say alloy
alloy okay so let's go back to the
survey that we just did all of these
materials excuse me all of these
instruments that we all use all of them
have circuitry inside bonded together by
this solder that holds it in to get
holds together unfortunately all those
things eventually end up here in a
landfill so in five to ten years all
those items will end up in a landfill
now what I didn't mention is that the
solder actually contains a material that
we aren't too crazy about it it contains
lead all right and lead is bad for the
environment so we have all these
wonderful devices that are fantastic but
they'll eventually end up here they'll
eventually give off their lead put it
into the water table and will be
something that we'll have to deal with
because lead is toxic to us into animals
and the like so let's talk a little bit
about lead the good the bad and the ugly
if you look at the periodic table the
lead the symbol for lead is PB it comes
from the Latin plumbum can you say that
plumbum magic only lead plumbum it's
actually the same derivative that we use
for the word plumber so that that might
look familiar to you
bum bum now the reason why that's the
case is that in ancient times plumbers
used lead quite a bit and if you look at
ancient times sort of like the Coliseum
you would see things like this you would
see coins made out of lead and you would
see right here is a duct or a pipe made
out of lead in a very very old sidewalk
and that was used to move water from one
part of the city to another and now we
use lead in these electronics so from
the civilization point of view lead has
served us but let's look at the bad and
the ugly well we do include it sometimes
in paint and so that's why you have to
be careful never to put paint chip in
your mouth that's not good because you
could get poisoned that way and some old
cars there's gasoline that contains some
lead lots of old batteries contain lead
as well so for the most part this stuff
is dangerous
it's really bad it's it's poisonous so
we really don't want to have lead all
right
you don't want leg so the question I'm
asking is how do you get the lead out
crazy picture I know how do we make sure
how do we have solder 's that don't have
lead in them that's the question that we
propose well okay so we have solder and
what it's consisting of is tin and lead
but we want to get rid of the lead so
what can we use to replace the let the
lead well other scientists have looked
at different combinations of metals
different alloys and they found that tin
silver is actually a very good
combination and might be the replacement
for ten lead however they found out one
thing that although it can work
similarly to tin lead it's not as
strongest Inlet so tin lead is bad for
us but it's really strong here we have
something that's better for us but it's
not as strong and sometimes it happens
in science you just have these
trade-offs so the question that we're
going to ask is if we start off with tin
silver what can we do to strengthen it
so that it has properties similar to
that lead-based alloy which is toxic
question I can add more make it thicker
yeah that's one thing we can do but
those devices did you see those devices
how small they are we're actually
getting smaller is your cell phone
getting bigger is it getting smaller
smaller everything's getting smaller so
although putting a large chunk of it
will work that works in the lab we're
all we're all going in the direction
where we're getting smaller and smaller
okay so the issue is that in silver on a
very small scale is still too weak
compared to LEDs so what can we do so
the question is how do we strengthen
materials well this is what material
scientists do all the time this is my
job all right how do you strengthen
materials and we're familiar with
strengthening materials anybody have
gold I'm not gonna take it
anybody have gold on all right I have
gold on I brought war today
Gold is actually a very very soft metal
it's a very soft metal however we're
able to have it on our necks
we're able to have it in our ears our
teeth
some people have it in their noses how
is it how is it that we're able to
sustained this soft material is able to
sustain such a aggressive and abrasive
and I even nasty environments how is it
able to do that well we put other metals
into the gold we put nickel and we put
copper and we alloy it so that it's
strong enough so that's one thing that
we can do we can alloy material to
strengthen it here's another way that we
can strengthen it material I have a
demonstration here I have two types of
cakes here and a knife okay so if I
wanted to slice a pound cake which is
made out of pound of sugar pound of
butter pound of whatever this is just a
pound cake and a fruitcake and I were to
sliced them which one would be more
difficult to slice the pound cake
alright let's let's do it by a show
hands pound cake fruitcake
okay everybody believes me okay so
here's my pound cake look at that that
goes right through here's here's another
cake with nuts in it taking me a little
bit more effort now why is that why is
it that we why is it that the fruitcake
is harder or in this case the but the
banana nut cake is harder there's more
stuff in it what everybody agreeing that
we're with that there's stuff that's
preventing my knife from slicing through
alright so this process of putting stuff
into stuff is actually how it has a
technical term it's called dispersion
hardening dispersion means stuff we put
stuff into stuff to make it harder okay
can you say dispersion hardening that's
just a technical term for stuff into
stuff alright so we're gonna put stuff
into stuff to make it harder so we had
tin silver solder and now we're going to
put stuff into it to make it harder so
scientists have have come up with a
couple of ways or a couple of materials
that they've put into these Sauter's as
well what we decided we want to do is
that we wanted to add iron we wanted to
add iron to strengthen this material so
we're putting stuff iron into stuff the
tin silver solder to see if it will
increase its strength okay there
I'm bored with what we're doing alright
well let's look at some data alright
let's see what happens when we do that
so what I have here is a bar graph and
let me explain what's going on the
taller the bar the more strength okay
and so I have a couple of examples here
where I have no particles so it has no
orange dots in it I have one with 10%
particles so it has 10% orange dots in
it I have a case with 20% iron particles
so it has 20 of these aren't dots
25 25 orange dots do you see that okay
so the difference between no particles
and 10 particles you can see that it's
significantly different right would you
agree all right so we're increasing the
strength by adding stuff to stuff so
that's the first thing that we've
learned the second thing is that well if
you keep going you don't you don't gain
very much you can see that 25 and 20 not
that much of a difference but when you
go from nothing to something it's a
significant amount significant change in
the strength would you agree with that
okay so adding particles increases the
strength whoops what did I do
all right so success we feel pretty good
about that we did what we thought we're
gonna do we increase the strength so can
I sit back and go on vacation no how'd
you know no not quite there because it
ends up that when we put those particles
into the solder that it actually became
too thick so the solder when it was
liquid when we melted it it poured like
water but when it was had too many of
these particles it poured like pudding
does putting poor very well no not
really
so it had too many particles in it so
we're not done although we've showed
that we can increase the strength it's
still not quite there because it's too
thick so what else can we do alright
well let's go back to our original
problem what should we add to the silver
and tin other people have used other
materials we're gonna stick with iron
because we know that it can increase the
strength but let's do this let's employ
the fact that iron is magnetic
you might be familiar with this so here
are some pieces can everybody see that
all right these are just small metallic
pieces and what I'm gonna do is I put a
very strong magnet and you see how
things align and move accordingly see
that you see how we see lines moving
here feel lines all right we'll get back
to this in just a second but iron is
magnetic and so we're gonna employ the
fact that it's in magnetic all right so
we'll get right back to that in just a
second
all right so whoops I want to go back to
much technology here all right so the
fact that it's magnetic you may be
familiar with iron you may have seen it
in things like this but the reason why I
recall I recall that iron was magnetic
is because one of my favorite toys was
this are you familiar with this guy you
don't know Willie Willie I recommend you
get it so okay with this guy you have
iron filings and you can move it and now
he has a little goatee little sideburns
he's a metrosexual so we're gonna leave
his hair without any hair okay so but
we're just relying on the fact that iron
filings can be changed or moved into
position using these magnetic particles
using these using a magnet well we went
back sorry about that okay so let's see
if we can organize let's go back because
this is a distracting let's see how we
can organize these particles okay so
let's go back to my solder I have the
tin silver solder which is in blue I
have the iron particles which are
indicated in orange and let's say that
we have this in its liquid form okay and
now we're going to put this solder in
between two magnets two magnets that are
attracted to each other
now these magnets want to get close to
each other because they're attracted to
each other but we're not going to let
them we're gonna let them stay at that
distance and keep the solder in between
okay so when we do that these guys have
a strong attraction
and everything in between is going to
feel that attraction would you agree all
right so what happens when we do that
well if I put my solder underneath in
between that two fields the iron
particles will align according to that
field does that make sense all right so
now we've been able to organize our iron
particles before they were completely
random but by setting them in a magnetic
field we're able to align them along the
magnetic field so that makes sense okay
so here's how we're able to organize
them so let's see what kind of behavior
we get in terms of their strength based
on it being organized well if we look at
this bar chart again once again
increased height means greater strength
and so we're gonna look at the case
where we have no particles it has no
orange orange balls in it we have a case
where we have random particles so we
have randomly oriented orange balls and
then we have organized particles where
the orange balls are kind of all lined
up and you can see that the orange balls
that are all lined up have a greater
strength than all of them you see that
so we've been able to modify the
strength of the materials not only by
putting particles into the material
putting stuff into stuff which is
dispersion hardening right dispersion
hardening can you say that again so
we've done dispersion hardening but now
we're also making our particles align
and increasing the strength as well all
right
so in our minds just to show you what
that looks like if we were to look using
a scanning electron microscope so these
microscopes are about this big and they
cost like half a million dollars and
they actually allow you to look very to
very small features and here you can see
an image of random particles I'll show
you what we have we have the light gray
area that's the solder that's the tin
silver solder and the darker regions
that's the iron do you see any kind of
regular pattern it's just scattered all
over right it kind of looks like the
surface of the Moon right just
completely scattered however if we have
a sample that was made between these two
magnets we see that we
a band you see that's a little darker
here iron particles there's less here
and there's more over here so they don't
completely align that like they did in
my image but they kind of band together
they kind of group together all right
and it's this material and I show the
arrows to kind of indicate where the
field lines would be so this is what the
organized particles look like and we saw
that the organized particles had greater
strength than those that were randomly
oriented so from our point of view this
problem is solved all right so we
believe oh I want to show you one other
thing that we didn't even expect and
this happens in science too sometimes
you want to solve a problem and then you
just try something a lab and you see
something new let's look and see what
happens when we when we heat up the
solder and we place a magnet over it
does your solder do that so we're able
to move it vertically we moved it
vertically and where it can also move it
side to side that's kind of neat huh all
right so what's going on those iron
particles that are inside of the solder
they're attracted to the magnet so they
move up to the magnet but they bring the
solder along with it as well so we're
able to move things vertically and we've
actually made a whole bunch of different
shapes Y shapes you know army guy shapes
using this kind of technology yes that
magnets not very strong that's a
refrigerator magnet it's a refrigerator
man not very strong okay so sometimes in
science you aim to solve a problem and
sometimes you find something else that's
neat and we're actually writing papers
and patenting this because this is a way
to bomb things using vertical directions
what you used to do is you would have to
put a layer put solder put another layer
put solder now we're saying stack up
those layers heat it up and put a
magnetic field and the solder will go up
all right so those are some of the neat
things that we're doing with this
material so with apologies to the bionic
man we feel that we've made a material
that's stronger because we've dispersion
hardened it so that it will have
properties equal to that of the
lead-based materials it's greener
because we don't have any lead in it and
it's
master because boy we can do some neat
things we can move it upwards as well
right so mission accomplished I'm gonna
change gears now and any questions so
far
okay I'm gonna talk to you a little bit
about small stuff now I had talked a
little bit about putting iron particles
into solder and those iron particles
were on the scale of microns your hair
is on the scale of microns your hair is
about 60 microns and the particles were
about 60 microns now I want to do is I
want to talk about particles that are
one ten thousandth that thickness
all right so very small on the order of
nano so let's talk a little bit about
that first let's define this thing
called nano technology nano well that's
just a way to say very very small and
I'll be specific about that in just a
second and technology which is just a
new pathway a new way to create and
innovate so how small is nano all right
what I have here is tape measure that's
out to about a meter you guys familiar
with these things all right so if I have
a semi meter that's about here right now
let me get back to this guy if I have a
centimeter you may be familiar with
centimeters centimeters are these guys
here what's it's two three four or five
right and there's hominy in a meter a
hundred right now millimeter millimeter
of these smaller smaller lines that are
in between the centimeters and that's
1,000 right there's a thousand of them
in a meter all right then we have Micro
Micro is in between the millimeter you
thought millimeter was small we're gonna
do micro micros in between those
millimeters all right and there's a
thousand in there and in between those
lines there's a thousand more of these
nano lines they're not on this thing you
can't see it they're very very small
okay
so it's very very tiny and it's very
very stuck very very tiny so if I have a
meter which is what I have here nano is
one billionth of this length one
billionth of this
you cannot see it alright just to give
you an another way to look at this a
sheet of paper you have a sheet of paper
in front of you
sheet of paper is a hundred thousand
nanometers thick all right a human hair
fifty thousand nanometers thick all
right I don't have as much as most of
you but it's still fifty thousand
nanometers thick and your fingernail it
grows one nanometer per second so by the
time you say one Mississippi it's grown
one nanometer so let's try it one
Mississippi one nanometer is wrong okay
so let me just go back to so here I have
an image of a human hair this is also
taken with a scanning electron
microscope and across that would be
fifty thousand nanometers alright so if
you can pull out a hair don't hurt
yourself
can you see the diameter that diameter
is this big fifty thousand nanometers
across you cannot see that that's how
tiny it is okay so so nanotechnology is
based on two things this is my
definition it's small which I tried to
get across to you it's one billionth of
a meter a season one billionth of a
meter but the other part is that it's
curious curious is just a fancy way to
say it acts weird acts differently
professors we like to say things like
we're really smart but it's just another
say it's weird all right so it's smart
and it's weird alright I'll give you an
example will by what I mean by that
let's say that I have a machine that can
shrink things down to the nano size all
right so this is not a real dog so don't
write any letters to anybody okay so
this is a dog and I've put it in my
machine and I'm going to shrink it and
as I shrink it it gets smaller and
smaller and smaller turns into a cat
that's nanotechnology all right it was a
dog at our scale and it becomes a
different animal and another scale I'll
give you an example that makes that a
little bit more clear what color is gold
gold yeah yellow gold
all right let's say that I had gold
particles that were a hundred
all right so I can put about 500 of them
across your hair all right 100
nanometers pieces of pieces of gold nano
go and I were to suspend it in water it
it's color is red all right so it's
properties change so it got it's gone
from a dog to a cat the properties are
very different the color has changed
okay so that's what we mean by
nanotechnology and you can continue to
tailor this cup this color actually here
is another material that acts like a
nano goal in one way it's called quantum
dots and if you change the size from 2
minutes 2 nanometers to 8 nanometers you
get this range of colors just like a
beautiful rainbow right so it's
properties also are changed by the size
of the of the particles now what's going
on there's an interaction between the
light and the nano particle that
actually causes it to excite different
colors than if it were in a in in bulk
so that's what I meant by small and
curious it just acts weird Gold is no
longer gold it's red that's really
strange
all right so what are some of the uses
for nano gol it's still this is still a
technology that's in it in its Genesis
and here a couple of things that have
kind of come up to the surface one it
might be used for cancer treatments you
know it can be which I'll show a small
movie about in just a second it can be
used for environmental cleanup the nano
goal will go to a toxin and pull it out
and be a filter on a very very small
scale and it also can be used for drug
delivery let's say that I have a problem
with my foot and I need to take medicine
for what I would currently do is I would
take a pill pill to go all throughout my
body and hopefully enough of it makes it
to my foot right now with with
nanotechnology you can have medicines
that you can take and they will just
wait until they get to the location all
right and then release the medicines so
that's that's what the that's what
scientists are working on right now so
let me show you a little bit of a small
movie on the cancer treatments just so
you can appreciate what's going on
everybody see
that's hot literally so what's going on
here we have the nanoshells
that go directly to the tumor we shine a
laser light the laser light doesn't
affect our skin it's at a different
frequency
it doesn't affect our skin but it can
directly interact with the nanoparticles
and heats them up now what would be the
alternative if we didn't do such a
technique well if we had something bad
in our bodies our two options right now
are surgery and chemotherapy you might
end up with a hair cut like mine so this
is an alternative to that right this
approach so let's talk a little bit more
positively about some things that are
out there what nanotechnology
applications are there are out right now
well there's antibacterial coatings made
out of silver nanoparticles and they're
being embedded in socks and in some toys
and what does that mean for us no more
smelly socks all right so maybe you can
get a pair for dad all right and also
you don't have to worry about toys being
nasty after your brother or sister has
coughed up on it because you don't have
to worry about that because it has these
these nanoparticles that are
antibacterial there's also stain
resistant pants which is something I can
definitely use these stain resistant
pants aren't based on having
nanoparticles of silver but they're
based on borrowing information from
nature
specifically the lotus leaf the lotus
leaf as you can see has water that just
kind of balls up on it right and if you
pour water on it the water will just
spill right off why is that the case
because it has a surface that looks like
this it's got whiskers that are sticking
out and it prevents water from from
flattening out and seeping into the
pants so by balling up sort of like
water that you see on the surface of a
car that's really clean that's that's
what we're proof that's the surface that
we're creating with those pants so that
the water never gets a chance to seep in
but just rolls right off right so these
are some of the things that already
exist and what's in the future well
there's definitely applications in
medicine I had
about drug delivery there's some
applications of for medical imaging here
I have two images this is the same
patient we're looking at an x-ray and
you can see when you use nano gold you
get more contrast you can see these
kidneys much better than over here so
from a medical point of view there's
some applications there's lots of
environmental applications and also I
was looking on the web there's already
health and beauty here's nano gold
lipstick which is supposed to be more
luminescence and also some toothpaste
which I don't know what the cause is but
these things are out here and also
there's always military and space
applications so in our time together I
hope that you have learned a little bit
about how we engineer materials and I
also hope that you're convinced that the
next big thing is actually very very
small in fact it's nano thanks for your
attention